[Musique]
alors les buts dans les 12 coups de midi
un nouveau candidat il s'appelle paul
hill et hilary les asperger il est
formidable des images fortes cyclisme il
est extrêmement doué il a une mémoire
c'est plus une mémoire qui la ccc
nominal ces as du talent dans le déjà à
près de cent mille euros de gains et a
question qu'on se pose c'est est ce que
la production va faire en sorte qu'il
reste le plus longtemps qu'eux aussi
puissent qu'on s'est rendu compte que
plus un candidat rester dans l'émission
est plus l'audience montée on vous a
fait un petit récap ses parts et en
images
c'est la devise des jeux télé plus un
champion gagne plus l'audience grimpe
ça joue sajou ou sajoo et oui retrouver
son candidat préféré tous les jours à la
même heure et le voir triompher ça plaît
aux français et plusieurs jeux télé
exploiter ce filon dont les 12 coups de
midi le jeu dans lequel christian cazade
avait remporté plus de 800000 euros en
six mois d'antenne
on essaye de tourner la page grâce à
paul un nouveau champion pas tout à fait
comme les autres notre chérif au grand
coeur le grand paul le jeune homme
atteint du syndrome d'asperger une forme
d'autisme passionne la france et a déjà
gagné plus de 100000 euros dont elle va
laisser des traces sur son passage
ça c'est sûr reste juste à savoir
combien de temps il va rester jusqu'à ce
que les audiences décline peut-être bon
de 10,8
et bien kevin de n'oubliez pas les
paroles sur france 2 dit banco lui aussi
avec 418 laurence est le meilleur on 43
participation pas mal mais le jeune
homme a fini par perdre c'était à l'été
2010 8
il reste le recordman du jeu et ses
envolées lyriques nous manque énormément
sur ses pas
ces choses là
et en ce moment dans l'autre je
feuilletonnant de nagui un autre
champion hamas les victoires et les
euros il s'agit de jean-michel le
champion face aux champions on l'a bien
compris entre les champions et les
productions c'est un échange de bons
procédés argent versus audience alors
les productions favorise-t-elle parfois
leur champion pour faire plus d'audimat
les principaux concernés nous assure que
non jean-luc la vérité on dit toujours
la vérité
alors c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un
très un accord phénoménal en plus commis
comme il a le cerveau qui va très très
vite il est très concentré parfois il
fait des crises je crois que la la la la
maman de deux pôles a tenu à remercier
jean jean luc reichmann pour permettre
de gérer ses membres de deux clubs voilà
vous avez tout juste derrière moi alors
est ce que oui ou non
asile est ce que oui ou non cela prendra
trois autres qui restent le plus
longtemps possible sachant qu'il est
tellement cultivé il a tellement de
ressources qui peut casser le jeu alors
j'ai eu les infos pas uniquement par
rapport à lui mais globalement c'est
orienté oui la réponse est oui c'est pas
truqué mais s'est orientée de deux
manières pendant les tournages
ils sont capable maintenant de détecter
les points forts et les points faibles
au fil des tournages du candidat en
matière de culture générale il ya des
questions qui peuvent être posées en
fonction de ses forces pour laisser plus
longtemps et pas et aussi pour moment du
questionnaire vous savez on avait des
leurs et contrôler casting oui on avait
déploré que ce soit pas un questionnaire
sur la personnalité c'est un questionner
rythme sur les connaissances là il
détecte les forces et les faiblesses et
ensuite ils peuvent poser ou non des
questions et je vous rappelle que en
france c'est pas calé en amérique la
production envoie des questions au fur
et à mesure et peut les changer en
fonction du candidat de son degré de
connaissance dans tel ou tel domaine
donc c'est totalement aménagée amoureux
d'inières siècle alors juste pour vous
dire aussi qu'il est tellement il est
tellement bon ce candidat paul que lors
d'une question il y avait une erreur
franchement là alors il ya que lui qui
l'a vu parce que personne n'avait vu il
y a en fait des photos de henri ii et
henri iii magali dites moi donc qui est
ce monsieur alors c'est apple
alors non alors là je pense que c'est je
pense que c'est henry 2 ça oui bien
synchronisés rue de javel chaussures de
m
[Applaudissements]
et l'autre et le voilà en métro où il
est connu avec sa plume horrifique
il y en a d'autres qui l'ont la plus
meilleure on savait donc ça c'est en
rideau rétro et d'huile a vu lors de la
question qu'on avait interverti les
portraits à verser le donc c'est
évidemment encore et quoi il a refait
cette semaine mercredi sur les dates de
naissance et de mort de guillaume
apollinaire naoui l'enregistement à vous
le savez vous mais vous vous sans vous
avez fait trente ans de télé dont 35 me
tendez la perche votre perche
oui je la prends les plaisirs web méfiez
vous quand même à gagner apollinaire un
coup là-bas pollueurs
guillaume apollinaire il a fait la ville
a vécu reposer numéro 3 non par contre
la saison 5
maintenant c'est vrai je me cognais
j'aime apollinaire c'est un poète de
10/20 web abbas qu'elle a soufflé
christine kelly alors si vous avez des
effectivement c'est un poète est ce que
oui j'étais un poème moi de guillaume
apollinaire
non non c'est derrière vous allez merci
allez je voulais ce je vous laisse aller
sur votre père était trompé il a viré sa
mort en 1910 et non me racontez pas le
sac pas fait tant de télé que ça dure
c'est bon ça il est passé de 11 à
regarder l'extrait
effectivement il a corrigé une fois de
plus les lancers de la question il
répond surtout guillaume apollinaire
paul 1890-1918 z en à 1917 mais je fais
confiance à peu oui mais c'est bien 1918
il mort deux jours avant la remise
moulin 9 novembre
c'est ce que je disais que cette les
gars pour réviser vos impôts police et
lui
je vois la pole
il est mort deux jours avant l'armistice
oui il est mort de la grippe espagnole
qu'il était vital aux polonais histoire
de dire introduit un oui oui oui les
mâts pour lynn harris de cos trop vite
ce qui merci poule
il vient d'effacer 100 de milo rau et vu
son degré de connaissance
il peut aller très très très loin lui
c'est une exception alors il est comme
moi quand j'étais sa lancée du sang demi
pour que 5 et sonore qui va exploser
tous les records il va exploser tous les
records
et je vais vous dire pourquoi tf1 va
faire en sorte de le garder tf1 à son
gros carton de cette recette dernière
rentrée c'était good doctor avec le dr
shawn murphy fausse querelle atteint du
même syndrome que paul ils vont en faire
le héros de tf1 je vous jure qui va
aller il va exploser les records
on va oublier les grands joueurs juste
après le passage de paul est persuadé
alors donc on est tombé d'accord vous
pensez que les candidats sont non pas
avantagés ah oui mais on va ouvrir qui
sont gérées les deux russes et deux
latéraux plus ils ont besoin de
réhabilitation et comment ces huit
figures idéales emblématique ça va
restaurer l'image
je vais demander à la voie du sage quand
elle parle madame kelly tout s'arrête le
temps s'arrête non mais je veux dire que
c'est aussi un très bel espoir pour nous
aujourd'hui
ouvert à tous pour les personnes qui
sont atteintes justement dans ce
syndrome d'asperger il y en a beaucoup
de se dire que c'est possible il ya une
porte possible on est déficient quelque
part on a des chances ailleurs autre
chose il ya eu il ya des avantages mais
il ya aussi des gens qui sont forts
comme lui mais il ya aussi des triches
on se souvient de la version anglaise de
qui veut gagner oui avec quelqu'un dans
l'alsace
voilà exactement donc il ya aussi les
tristes on apprécie quand c'est pas de
la triche ans